Speaker 1: One of the things I've talked about
with you guys over the years is not unique
to the United States, but it's particularly
bad in the United States, which is when you
have the degree of connections between media
figures who are ostensibly journalists or
reporters are supposed to be people that are
sort of critically analyzing and talking to
you about what government is doing when you
have those media people so closely tied in
with, friendly with, involved with whatever
the very people in government that they're
supposed to be covering.
You don't really get journalism by definition
or in any real sense of the word.
And one of the things that we've seen over
time over the last year since the January
six Trump riots is the degree to which right
wing media like Fox News and others are so
connected.
We're so connected to the Trump administration.
We've learned about these text messages that
were exchanged between Sean Hannity and Mark
Meadows and others in the aftermath of the
Trump riots about how best to manage it and
how this is a bad thing.
And Trump's got to stop talking about the
stolen election.
But then he would go on the air and he would
support the Trump narrative and do something
totally different and part of what goes on.
And I've talked about this before because
I've been in some of these circles before
on the periphery is people don't want to lose
access, and that influences a lot of how media
behaves.
They become an acquaintance of someone in
power.
They start to get access to them.
And next thing you're, you know, you're Maria
Bartiromo, who has a direct line to Trump
and nods along to any insane notion that he
mentions.
So that's one piece of it that we don't want
to lose access part.
The other part of it is how they're actually,
in some cases, is almost no daylight between
the media and the government piece.
And there's now an explosive new report with
another little chapter in that.
Sean Hannity, Fox News propagandist, sent
Trump's former White House press secretary
Kayleigh McEnany a post riot playbook, according
to newly released texts.
Fox News's Sean Hannity reports HuffPost sent
Kayleigh McEnany a plan to handle Trump the
day after the deadly Capitol riot, according
to new, newly released text messages.
Hannity message McEnany on January 7th with
a quote five point approach for conversations
with Trump.
Hannity was telling McEnany how to manage
Trump, according to a letter that the White
House that the House committee investigating
the riots released on Thursday.
The first two items on Hannity's plan of action
read No more stolen election talk.
Again, this is this is a trend.
Hannity recognized that the stolen election
talk was not helping Trump to.
Yes, impeachment and 25th Amendment are real,
and many people will quit.
So it seems like Hannity is telling McEnany
say to Trump, you could be impeached.
The 25th Amendment could be used.
Your allies will quit if that happens.
Sort of like to warn Trump.
And the letter didn't reveal points three,
four and five, and McEnany responded in those
text messages.
Love that.
Thank you.
That is the playbook I will help reinforce,
Hannity told McEnany.
It was quote key that quote no more crazy
people were allowed to access the then president.
McEnany responded, Yes, 100 percent.
McEnany Days In the days after the election,
remember that McEnany appeared with those
crazy people, Sidney said.
I'm trying to think I believe there was one
particular press conference, and I don't know
if it's the one where Rudy's face melted.
I don't know.
It's all kind of a blur.
But McEnany appeared remember in her role
as a Trump campaign staffer, not as the press
secretary, alongside some combination of Sidney
Powell, Jenna Ellis and or Rudy Giuliani.
And yet McEnany knew and agreed that these
are crazy people around the president.
So there's three, four or five different important
layers here.
One is this cozy relationship between Fox
and the Trump administration wasn't serving
anybody.
You had people at Fox and people around Trump
who knew how insane this all was.
I mean, listen, quite frankly, we now have
text messages that show us Kaley and Hannity
both thought there were crazy people around
Trump giving him bad ideas.
The stolen election talk was a bad idea, and
yet they both went out and reinforced it,
showing that this was not them behaving on
principle.
This was them behaving on, call it, self-preservation
for McEnany.
Call it ratings for Hannity, maintaining access
to Trump, whatever.
So that's one aspect of this.
And then of.
Number two, that nobody is better off when
you have this, journalism is not better off,
the American people are not more informed.
The people running government are not running
government in a way that is better for the
people.
Everybody loses in these situations and I
know that there will be there will be people
who say, Well, you know, Chris Cuomo seemed
to be pretty friendly with Hillary Clinton
back in 2016.
They clearly know each other.
Yes, they clearly have.
The Clintons and the Cuomo clearly seem to
know each other.
But there was not this operationally indistinguishable
relationship that was going on when it came
to governance.
And it just doesn't.
It seems like such a lame comparison when
you now see the connections between Fox and
the Trump administration.
So here's just, you know, the text messages.
Just another example.